if you're struggling with lock down
perhaps take inspiration from 99
year-old Tom Moore his days in isolation
are motivated by helping others with the
aid of his walking frame he's steadily
making laps of the garden to raise money
for NHS workers but the speed of
donations has left him stunned we didn't
think he'd go anywhere at all it was
just a little family affair but then
when it started to take off I think
we're all amazed that couldn't believe
as we film a call comes in for Tom and
his daughter Hannah to appear on an
American radio station
Tom's fundraising has gone global as a
global nation we're looking for
something to hold us together and and
magically this has become it not in
exactly what we set out to do but we're
now sharing this with the whole world
this is the world story not ours tom
says the NHS looked after him when he
had skin cancer and a broken hip now
with the body they helped keep going
into old age he wants to repay what the
NHS did for him the difference that this
is making is firstly it's going straight
to the frontline of the NHS the
volunteers the patients and supporting
them so creating rest and recuperation
centres for staff is buying electronic
devices like iPads for patients who are
isolated to be able to speak to their
families and friends during the Second
World War
Tom served in the Army in Burma and
India his wartime stoicism is still
evident and his optimism is proving
uplifting in these dark times this is
such a it's a global thing you can't get
out and thump it to do anything like
that you've got to all the medical
people are doing their best to get
through and we will get
that I think you've got everybody gotta
remember we will go through eventually
heading in for a well-earned rest tom
says he'll continue making laps of the
Gordon just as long as people keep
sponsoring him Lisa Holland Sky News
Bedfordshire